RYAN: Hello, everyone.
Welcome back for the last
session of the day here.
And we're culminating
with a really great
session here by Yanick.
Yanick is from EA and he's
going to come up and talk
about how they've built their
mobile games servers on Google
App Engine.
So really practical use of a lot
of the things that you've
learned today, and he's going
to give you some tips and
tricks as well.
So welcome, Yanick.
YANICK BELANGER: Thank
you, Ryan.
So hello, my name is Yanick
Belanger, I'm a
architecture lead--
server architecture lead at
Electronic Arts, specifically,
at the playing [INAUDIBLE]
studio up there in Montreal.
If you want to know, yes, we
still have that much snow up
there in Canada.
So I'm here today to talk about
how we integrate Google
App Engine in our development
of our mobile game servers.
OK?
I'm not a sales guy.
I'm not here to promote App
Engine, I'm not here to
promote our games as well.
I'm simply here because we
believe in my team that Google
App Engine is really an amazing
piece of technology.
So let's jump first on a really
quick scenario, OK?
Let's say you're a small
game company.
You've developed an amazing
new game, OK?
It's going to be awesome.
This game is a multiplayer
games.
You have your server ready.
It sits right under your desk
using this old Pentium that
was laying around.
OK?
And you launch the
game, finally.
It's a great game.
It gets immediate success.
It's a viral game.
Everybody talks about it.
You get a major response
from the market.
But eventually, what you see
is that your old machine is
smoking badly and you
get [INAUDIBLE].
So how can you prevent that?
You have to plan for success.
And typically, using a standard
technology stack on
the server side, it means that
you have to invest a lot of
money and time and resources in
proving that your platform
will stay alive in the event
of a successful game.
That's where Google App
Engine make sense.
It makes sense for small
companies, and it also makes
sense for big companies
like EA.
So what's App Engine exactly?
OK.
I'm not here to describe in
details what's App Engine.
I mean, we, during the previous
sessions we had a
pretty good overview of
what's App Engine.
There's tons of good resources
on the internet, good videos
that describes what's
App Engine.
But let's say a quick
overview of what is
this platform exactly.
It's a platform as a service
Cloud computing.
It means that you sit--
your application will
sit on top of a
very high level platform.
It's pretty different than a
IAAS infrastructure as a
service platform where you
basically have to manage your
OS, your software stack.
App Engine, as I said, is
a high level platform.
You have no infrastructure
to manage.
You can build your application
using Java, Python or Go.
It's built using
existing Google
technology and Google services.
It's the same type of technology
that's used for
their search engine,
for example.
It's also automatically
scalable.
It's an auto scaling system,
which means they will allocate
new instances for you as your
traffic goes up and deallocate
dues when the traffic
goes down.
So at the end you pay
for what you use.
At EA we use App Engine
to develop
mobile connected games.
They all have a pretty strong
integration with social networks.
Most of them are asynchronous
turn-based games, so
multiplayer games, but we also
have single player games.
We use other solutions for
two types of game.
Real time is kind of hard to
achieve on App Engine because
it's a shared infrastructure
with thousands of other
application, to have a
predictable timing on App
Engine is pretty hard.
OK?
So we have a different
solution for that.
For casino-like games--
this is pretty interesting
because for casino game you
need really quick
synchronization with your server.
And that's currently not
possible from App Engine
because they don't support a
dedicated channel between
mobile client and your server.
They have a pretty
good technology.
They're a channel service for
web clients, but there's
nothing for mobile
clients yet.
It doesn't mean you can't use
a hybrid solution where you
would host all the non-real time
aspect of your game on
App Engine to manage profile,
manage matchmaking, your
manager micro transactions.
And have a separate system
hosted, for example, on
Compute Engine or you're
in-house system for the real
time aspect of the game.
They're delivering
high quality.
That's an interesting topic.
App Engine is really an easy
platform to work with.
You can quickly code and
deploy, in a matter of
minutes, an application on App
Engine and like that it's
available on the internet.
It will scale.
It's all great.
That being said, don't expect
to code quickly something on
App Engine and expect your
application to have a great,
great quality.
You have to have best practices,
technical knowledge
of the platform.
You have to add up
job processes.
So I'll give you a quick review
of our approach to
achieve high quality servers
on App Engine.
And how we leverage the platform
strength to do it.
First, this is really
important.
This is not something everybody
understand at first,
but we need to keep everything
as simple as possible.
App Engine itself is pretty
simple to use.
They have a simple API.
So we need to keep everything
pretty simple.
Why?
Well, first, by keeping your
implementations and your
design simple, you get the
more consistent quality.
You get an application that is
easier to learn for the new
developers.
You get a platform that
is easier to refactor.
OK?
For example, we don't add use
lists abstractions on top of
App Engine.
We connect directly
to their API.
If is no real goal, no real
benefit of having an
abstraction, we don't do it.
These are the basic principles
of agile software development.
App Engine offers a great API.
So why should we add an
abstraction on top of it if we
don't need to?
OK?
We don't over engineer
our solutions.
We code for the requirement
we have today, not for the
requirements we're going
to have next week.
And we try to keep the design
as simple as possible so we
can refactor the design next
week when we have new
requirements.
We also leverage a lot
third-party libraries.
There are tons of
them out there.
We use JAVA for our
game servers.
And there are really great
third-parties like Google
Guice for dependence injection,
Jersey for your
RESTful API, Makito
for the unit test.
Those are all well-tested,
proven libraries that you
should use.
If you start coding something
that is there to solve a
common problem, you're
probably wrong.
There are tons of existing
libraries out there.
Use them.
We don't try reinvent the
wheel, basically.
We also use components
within the company.
There's no goal to recode
the same low
level stuff every time.
So we have what we call
our toolkit library--
App Engine tool kit library--
where you can find basically a
set of reusable components,
reusable building blocks.
They're all optional
building blocks.
It's not a framework, it's
pretty different.
And that's where we share across
all our games, the
common stuff to handle
matchmaking, for example,
micro transaction validations,
connection to external services.
Another approach we have is this
principle, test early and
test often.
The idea is that the cost of
finding a bug is exponential
as your development process
is going forward.
I mean, the best place to find
a bug-- this is not really a
test phase but it's a great
place to find a bug-- is in
your compiler, directly
in your editor.
You see right away when there's
an issue with the call
your doing.
You fix it.
It takes five seconds.
The investment is minimal.
OK?
You don't lose your time.
It's fixed.
We do unit testing.
These are great place, also,
to find your bugs.
And regression bugs, also.
We do unit test to test in
isolation our components.
App Engine offers a great set
of stubs for their services
that will help you a lot to
develop your unit test.
We also do integration test.
Integration test is basically
you want to validate that the
integration of your different
components is as expected.
OK?
You want test the
glue between the
loose components, basically.
We also use integration test
as a kind of a black box
testing, where we inject traffic
just like a real
client would do, and we
validate the result.
App Engine offers a great local
development environment
for that where you can start
easily on your development
machine server that will mimic
pretty well what you end up
having on a real Cloud.
So what we have, using Maven
for Java, we have a process
that will compile the server,
execute the unit test, start
the server, execute the
integration test and validate
that everything is OK.
And these steps take less than
two or three minutes, usually.
This aspect is very important.
It has to be fast so that
your developer will
run them every time.
You want to validate the
quality every time.
You want to test often,
basically.
And the last place you can
find your bug before they
reach the players is
in the QA team.
But this is costly.
Basically, you lose a lot of
time, it's a lot of money, a
lot of time when you
find bugs there.
It's preferable to find them
in the previous steps.
We also have a typical
continuous integration
environment that will build our
servers and test them on
every commit in our source
control system.
The build system will also
automatically deploy our new
versions on the App Engine
environment on the Cloud.
And some of these environments
we even switch on
automatically the new versions
so that another team can start
testing right away with
the new version.
We also have a dedicated team at
EA that is a specialized in
doing load test-- system test.
OK.
Even though App Engine isn't a
[INAUDIBLE] scaling system,
you still have to prove that
your application will scale
well on App Engine, that it
will perform well and at a
reasonable cost.
So, in summary, our approach to
achieve high quality on App
Engine is not rocket science.
I mean, we use basic agile
software development
principles.
We try to keep everything
as simple as possible.
We leverage the tools we have
in App Engine to death to
launch a local environment.
And, most of all, App Engine is
really a key component in
achieving high quality.
It basically handles
all the hard stuff.
It also gives you a great
SDK with great
documentation, nice tools.
So that's pretty neat.
You know, App Engine is a
very different platform.
It has some particularities.
It will generally scale and
perform well as long as your
application doesn't prevent
it to do so.
So we've learned over the past
two years some strategies and
good practices that I'd like
to share with you today.
These are not, by the way, the
absolute rules from God for
implementing stuff on App
Engine, but it's coming from
real games that are currently
on the market.
It works well.
So first of all, by building
your application on App
Engine, you leverage a lot of
Google's own technology.
And to make it work correctly
your application has to fit
the Google philosophy.
We call it the Googly
Will or Googly Way.
Depends on the reference.
The general goal with the Googly
way is to have a fast
and small request.
The idea is that the latency or
the response time is a good
indicator of the amount
of resource you're
using in your request.
So higher response time usually
means higher cost.
There are some tricks to improve
the response time on
App Engine.
I will cover them in the
next few sections.
Your application has to be
designed also to run on the
distributed environment.
But this is really an
abstract concept.
What does it mean exactly to
design an application to run
on a distributed environment?
Well, App Engine offers an API
that is an entry point to
they're distributed
infrastructure.
OK?
An entry point to distribute
your data and your processes.
So you have to use
them wisely.
That's pretty much
it on App Engine.
That's what it means to design
for a distributed
environments.
So I like the idea of having a
nice limited silo per user.
A nice limited data and
processing silo.
You keep every user as
independent as possible.
So that way the App Engine
runtime will distribute them
in their data centers.
In practice, though, it's almost
impossible to have well
isolated users.
You have things like
games, for example.
In a multi-player game a game
is shared between two users.
So it's not a real contention
point, but you still have to
handle the current currency.
A more extreme contention
point would be
a matchmaking queue.
This is really tricky
to implement.
It's a contention point because
everybody wants to
enter this queue, so you have
to manage that with care.
There are strategies to handle
contention points.
We'll give you some in
the next slides.
Something else we've learned
is that NoSQL is really
different than SQL.
We use a DataStore to store
pretty much all our data.
The DataStore on App Engine
is a NoSQL [INAUDIBLE]
persistence storage.
It's all managed by Google.
It's pretty cool.
You don't have to worry
about charting or
redundancies or backups.
It may look similar to your
normal relational database,
but there are fundamental
differences that requires a
major shift in the way you
design your storage.
One of the most common mistakes
that a new developer
with NoSQL will do is to try
to normalize its data, just
like it would do with
a normal SQL system.
This is a mistake because on
App Engine with a DataStore
you want to minimize the
number of operations.
These operations are costly
and longer than in your
typical SQL system, and you want
to handle them with care.
So by denormalizing your data
structure, you can achieve
some pretty good
optimizations.
By denormalizing, I mean, to
regroup and even sometimes to
duplicate your data.
I'll give you an example.
Let's take all the data that
is related to a player.
You have its profile,
you have some stats,
you have its purchases.
In our game we regroup them, all
loose data, in one entity.
It's called a player.
So that way we can optimize a
lot the operations we do with
the DataStore.
You also have to adapt your data
model for the use cases.
I'll show you some real world
use case later in this
presentation.
The way you access your data
is also quite different.
You're limited.
OK?
For example, with queries you
can't do a joint operation.
You can not do a query on
a non-index operation.
It limits a lot what
you can do.
You even have to modify your
data model sometimes to
execute a query.
So that's a hard constraint.
But it's there for the ultimate
goal, to reach high
scalability and high
reliability.
Also, one of the most important
things, I think,
about the DataStore is that
your developers must
understand very well
how it works.
OK?
You must read about
the DataStre.
You must understand everything
about the ancestors, the
eventually consistent queries,
the hot tablet issues you can
get that will compromise
your scalability.
You have to understand all that
because the DataStore is
going to be probably the most
used service in your
application, and it will drive
by itself probably half of the
cost of your running
instances.
I was talking about the
great third parties.
There are great third parties
to manipulate the DataStore.
For Java it's called
Objectifier.
For [INAUDIBLE]
it's called NDB.
Those are higher level APIs that
will handle stuff like
object mapping, transaction
management,
caching, auto retries.
They are great, great tools.
They will save you a lot
of lines of code.
Let's go to this last box.
Caching.
Well, for the last few slides
I've talked a lot about how to
lower the number for
operations you do.
A good way to achieve
that is to avoid
reaching the costly resources.
And caching is a good
way to avoid that.
OK?
It will lower your cost at the
end if you use caching wisely.
There are different techniques
to cache in different layers.
First I'll talk about
in-memory caching.
This is very limited because--
keep in mind that you have
multiple instances running
that host your applications.
In-memory caching is
not distributed
across these instances.
So it's very limited.
I'll give you an example
of what kind of
caching we do in-memory.
Let's say you have within your
application two components at
different times during
a request that
access a user profile.
Usually because they're well
isolated and well encapsulated
they don't talk to each other.
So one component will fetch
the user profile once and,
eventually, in your process, in
the same request, you fetch
through the other components
the same user profile.
So by adding a layer--
an in-memory caching layer--
you prevent paying the costs
for the second access.
But you have to be careful.
It's very limited.
The ultimate caching tool in
App Engine is Memcache.
Memcache is a low latency
distributed caching system.
And best of all, it's
free on App Engine.
It's totally free.
But it doesn't mean you have
to cache everything.
OK?
You have to be careful because
the space is limited and you
have to cache only the
most used resources.
Things that we cache
and memcache.
Well, pretty much all our
persistent data is cached.
Let's say if we fetch your
list of friends from your
favorite social network,
we cache
this information usually.
Another layer where you could
cache is by leveraging the
edge cache on Google's
infrastructure.
By using the proper HTTP cache
control header in your
response, you can enable this
caching in the Google front
end infrastructure.
So that way your next request
will hit the cache instead of
going to your application.
So you save a lot of
reparations there.
And finally, probably the most
effective place to cache is on
the client side.
This is not well implemented
in most of the games
I've seen so far.
But it's very efficient.
When you do it correctly,
there are known and well
defined HTTP caching mechanism
for client side caching with
headers like If None Match
and If Modified Since.
Those will greatly reduce your
operations on the server side.
We've also adapted other
techniques to
optimise our games.
First we try to reduce our
instant start up time as much
as possible.
This is especially a problem
with Java application because
the start up time is quite
hard than the Python
applications.
The idea is that App Engine will
allocate new instances
when your traffic goes up.
So if you take a long time to
start your instances, you
prevent App Engine from scaling
automatically and
efficiently.
I'll give you an example.
In one of our projects we had
a marketing campaign to send
push notifications
to all our users.
And within two minutes the
traffic jammed from the normal
rate to 30 times the
normal rate.
Something that would be almost
impossible to handle with a
traditional system.
Our application wasn't fully
optimized for a start up time
and we had some issues,
user impacting
issues, for a few minutes.
But, eventually, App Engine
managed to ramp up
efficiently.
We also use Appstats
for profiling.
Appstats is a nice tool.
It is provided with their SDK.
It will show you the resource
you use within your request.
So it helps a lot if you want
to target your optimization.
We use other techniques for
parallelism as well.
All kind of parallelism like
just multi-threat.
Sometimes you want to spawn a
new threat in your request and
do some job in the background.
We leverage the asynchronous
API for the
DataStore and memcache.
We also use the batch operations
for memcache and
the DataStore.
We use batch process
in our background
task as much as possible.
Those won't save you money,
they will just lower the
response time, basically.
In the next section I will cover
some typical feature we
have in our game.
Some typical feature,
not all of them.
Games are pretty complex
these days.
And I'll show you
how we implement
them using App Engine.
There may be other
implementation strategies,
it's up to you to decide if they
are appropriate or not.
OK.
First, the easiest feature, your
profile and game state
persistence.
It looks pretty simple.
You just called the DataStore
API, you store your
data, and that's it.
Problem solved.
But not so fast.
You have to be careful with
the design of your
persistence.
As I said, you have to
denormalize your data to
optimize your operations
and lower your costs.
And you have to design
the persistence by
looking at the use case.
Let's take the profile,
for example.
Well profile is pretty simple.
You have as much read
operations and write
operations, there's nothing
special about it.
But the game state
is different.
In some of our games the game
state has a lot of read
operations, and very few
write operations.
The reason is pretty simple.
We use, because we don't have a
dedicated channel to update
the client on the game state,
we use polling mainly in the
main screen of our games where
we see all the active games.
We have polling requests coming
in every 10 seconds
executing a query to have the
list of active games.
So this is a lot of costly
read operations.
You have to execute a
query plus a fetch
for all your games.
So we've adapted in some of our
games a technique called
materialized views where you
basically store the result of
a query concretely in
your DataStore.
And you update this
table on every
update on the game state.
So what you end up having is
really an entity that contains
the result that is expected
to display the
list of active game.
And it optimizes a lot the
number of operations required.
Those two examples
are not really--
doesn't represent really
a contention point.
OK?
There is no right contentions
with them, but you still have
to manage the optimistic
currency
nature of the DataStore.
You have to retry even though
if you use Objectify or NDB
they will handle that for
you automatically.
Social connectivity.
Well, pretty much all the games
these days have social
integration.
Everybody wants to play
against their friends.
It's all cool.
It's not that complex
to implement.
We use the URL fetch service
and memcache
to cache some resources.
For example, a typical call to
your favorite social network
will take maybe a few hundred
milliseconds.
It has an impact on
the response time.
It has an impact on the
user experience.
It has an impact
on your costs.
So we use memcache to
cache for x minutes.
The list of threats,
for example.
There is also a safety quota
on App Engine for URL fetch
operations.
There are quotas, by the way,
for pretty much all
operations, but the first
one you will hit is
probably the URL fetch.
And memcache helps a lot with
that so you lower your number
of fetch operations.
Next feature, mobile
push notification.
Mobile push notifications are
a complex beast to integrate
in your application.
Basically because there are a
lot of particularities with
all the different mobile
platforms out there.
It's not easy to implement and
there are-- you have to keep
in mind that there are third
party services out there that
offers a higher level, like a
kind of aggregated view that
will help you a lot
implementing push
notifications.
Those third party services
are costly, though,
so you have to choose.
Either you pay the cost of
implementing, or the cost of
using these third
party services.
In our case, since we have
multiple games we've decided
to connect directly to
the mobile platforms.
We use background
tasks for that.
This is a perfect example of
something you can do in
background.
You don't depend on the status
of these push notifications.
And background task are really
good because they will retry
automatically for you if they
are configured to do so.
For Android and Amazon we use
the URL fetch service to do an
HTTP call to their service.
For iOS it's a different
story.
OK? iOS use a custom protocol
on top of TCP and,
unfortunately, currently
we have no support--
no official support--
for socket connection from
an App Engine instance.
So we have in EA an in-house
system that will
handle that for you.
So our App Engine application
can [INAUDIBLE] through HTTP
to this system that will
push notification
on the socket protocol.
We are testing the new
experimental socket support in
App Engine and, currently,
it works pretty well.
We plan to have our next
game using the socket
implementation directly instead
of going through a
different system.
Client assets.
There are graphics, there are
sounds, there are client
configurations, all kinds of
resources that your client--
mobile client-- needs
at start up.
We usually serve them directly
from our App Engine
application.
There are different solutions
for that.
You can use Google Cloud
Storage, which
is a different system.
It's not directly related to App
Engine, but you can access
your data from App Engine.
It's more appropriate
for bigger assets.
It can handle pretty much
any size you want.
Monitor solution would be to
package these assets directly
in your App Engine
applications.
You have to mark them as being
public in your descriptor
file, so that way App Engine
will distribute them
automatically to their content
delivery network.
So you get an excellent
response time
anywhere in the world.
Matchmaking.
This is a beast, really.
It's not easy to implement
matchmaking.
Matchmaking making is the
process of matching two or
more random players together.
It's the perfect contention
point.
Everybody wants to write in
the matchmaking queue.
We have different techniques
to implement that.
First, the most used technique
we have is a component from
our toolkit named the
matchmaking service that is
implemented using memcache.
You can use memcache as
a short lived storage.
It's not reliable, but it
works well enough for
matchmaking.
Because it's not reliable, we
have a fallback mechanism that
is less optimal, but
it still works.
And we also have to implement
the [INAUDIBLE]
system on memcache because even
though memcache is really
fast, you still get some
contention issues as the
traffic goes up.
You can also use back end
instances on App Engine to
implement the matchmaking
queue.
Back end instances are a kind
of instance that is stateful
and long lived.
The problem, though, is that
they're not auto scaling, so
you have to manage
them by yourself.
But it's a very good place to
store the matchmaking queue
directly in memory.
There could be a third solution
for-- if you don't
plan for success, you could
store directly to matchmaking
queue in the DataStore.
But the contention is really an
issue with the DataStore.
You have--
you can probably write on a
given DataStore entity maybe
twice per second.
It's really an issue.
But if you don't plan for
success you could do it.
It works well.
Microtransaction validation.
It's a standard feature now in
most of the mobile games.
In-app billing is a reality.
We have to implement it.
The game server is the authority
for everything
related to transactions.
For security reasons we have
to validate they receipt on
the server side before
we apply the
result to the user profile.
There are tons and tons of
hacked requests coming from,
for example, jail breaking
iOS device.
For Android, it's only a
matter of evaluating a
signature using a certificate.
So it's all done directly
in the instance.
For Amazon and Apple you have
to do an HTTP call to their
system to validate
the transaction,
validate the receipt.
And last feature.
This is not directly related to
your game play, but it's an
important tool to optimize your
game balance, to optimize
your retention, optimize
your profitability.
It's business intelligence.
You need metrics to know what's
going on in your server.
Your analyst will basically need
a broad range of data to
do extraction and do aggregation
and extraction to
have the meaningful numbers.
We have, for example, a matrix
for the average number of
games per player, the sales
number per region.
These are valid matrix.
We have two strategies for
those matrix, currently.
First is to execute a MapReduce
directly in the App
Engine application.
This is not optimal.
It is limited because it
requires a code change every
time you want to extract
a new metric.
It's not really useful.
We are testing a new solution
to [? dam ?]
the data, the meaningful
evidence on BigQuery and give
our analysts access to the
BigQuery environments so they
can extract pretty much
anything they like.
So let's now introduce a
major buzz word in this
presentation.
Let's talk about DevOps.
Everybody wants to talk about
DevOps these days.
So let's get back to the
initial scenario.
You're a small company, you've
developed your game, it's
going to be amazing.
The server has been implemented
on App Engine this
time, so it's better.
Your game is bug free.
It's been load tested up to
gazillions of players.
It works well.
But there is still
something missing
before launching a game.
What's going to be your
support model?
The good news is Google site
reliability engineers monitor
the platform for you.
So most of the platform
is monitored by Google
themselves.
All you have to monitor is
really the interaction in your
thin layer that is
your application.
Your application is really just
a thin layer on top of
the platform.
A thin, stateless layer.
So what could go wrong
with this layer?
Well, things can go wrong
in this layer sometimes.
So, in this context, where
Google monitors the system for
you, does it still make sense to
use a standard multi-tiered
support model?
In our team we don't think so.
We're in transition to adapt
a full DevOp model.
And there are few reasons
for that.
First, their support team
is kind of redundant.
Let's take a typical scenario
where the system fails.
Their support team currently see
that there's an issue with
the system.
There are some metrics that are
wrong, so there is nothing
they can do, basically.
They can not reboot the servers,
they cannot execute a
job on the database.
So every time they end up
calling us and asking us,
what's going on, what
can we do with that.
On our side, most of
the time there's
nothing we can do either.
We look at the Google App Engine
status page, we see
there is an issue currently with
the platform, Google is
already working on it.
There's not much we can do.
We wait.
Often, in a matter of minutes,
it's resolved
and everybody's happy.
That was a pretty cool picture
that one of our managers took
during one of our down time
where we were sitting on
couches playing NHL 2013 while
the server was down, and
everybody was like, what
are they doing?
The server is down currently.
But there's nothing we can do.
Google's working on it.
No problem.
Another reason why we will adapt
the DevOp model is we
are already pretty much
responsible for all the
operation steps.
We deploy our application
ourselves.
We manage our application,
our App Engine
environments ourselves.
We handle pretty much every
aspect of operations.
We have short development
cycles.
We deploy every week, so we're
very close to have a real
DevOp model.
The only thing that is shaky
is the support from the
support team that we
want to remove.
And if there's an [INAUDIBLE]
to do, only us, the developer,
can do it.
Because your system is really
your code with App Engine.
So on the developer understands
well the dynamics
of the code and can
fix the problem.
So you need your developer
anyway.
The only thing missing with
App Engine is a proper
monitoring tool for your
application layer.
OK?
They don't prevent you from
developing your own system,
and that's what we've
done at EA.
We have basic metric
libraries that we
use to increase counters.
Those counters get transferred
periodically to a third party
monitoring system where we can
set thresholds and alarms.
And we get notified when
something is wrong.
So that's supposed to
be in production.
We're still using the Legacy
support model, but we're
moving to this system.
Well, that's pretty
much it, already.
Well, to summarize this
presentation, we're really
pleased with App Engine in
our game development.
It's been really
a great story.
We've been using it
for two years now.
We've learned a lot.
I think we achieved good
qualities with our systems
because of App Engine.
When it's been released, like
four years ago, App Engine, in
my opinion, was a
game changer.
It was really a right step
in the right direction.
It enables you to focus your
work on your game.
We are game developers.
We are not specialists--
infrastructure specialists--
so you can focus on
what you do best.
So it's a great system.
I recommend, really, everybody
to use it.
Thank you.
Do you have any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
YANICK BELANGER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: One quick question.
Why did you choose to use Java
to do all of your App Engine
programming as opposed to one
of the other languages?
YANICK BELANGER: That's an
interesting question.
Well, we had good Java
developers in our team.
Nobody knew Python
really well.
Go was a new language.
It would have been cool to use
Go but we decided to go with
Java because everybody knew
Java pretty well.
Actually, besides start up--
the increased start up time
on App Engine, Java
works pretty well.
Other questions?
Well, that's it.
Thank you, guys.